when you think about uh food and rent
electricity we went earlier and we
literally went through the august
numbers many of these are kind of staple
expenses uh in a monthly budget um
it feels like it's just affecting those
that are in the bottom 40 50 of the
population way more than they're
affecting the wealthy like the wealthy
are getting rich and those at the bottom
are getting hurt and we just get a
continuation of the wealth inequality
gap is that your read on this as well
well that's always the case right
because
the wealthier people don't spend nearly
as much of their incomes as the poor or
you know let's say the middle class
in many cases they have to spend
everything that they earn and so as the
cost of living goes up
it more immediately impacts their
quality of life because obviously if
you're spending everything you earn and
now the price of food goes up uh the
price of energy goes up you know you
have to cut back spending someplace else
i mean unless you've earned enough money
to equal the rise in cost and very few
people are i mean even if you look at
the government numbers wages are going
up much more slowly than prices
and so you're forced to cut back but
let's say you're very rich and let's say
you're earning a million dollars a year
and you're only spending 200 000 a year
you're taking the other 800 000 and
you're just investing it or saving it
and if now your cost of living goes up
and now you need 220 000 well you just
save a little bit less you invest a
little bit less but it doesn't come at
the expense of your standard of living
you're not giving up something that you
otherwise
had you're just you know you just don't
have enough left over
for savings and investing which has
negative consequences for the economy
because that's saving an investment is
what grows the economy and so if
somebody needs to save and invest less
because they need more to survive
because the cost of living has gone up
then that hurts society but as far as
the immediate pain for the individual
the more of your money that you spend
the more impactful rising costs are
that's why inflation is such a you know
a a heinous tax because it falls most
heavily on those who can least afford to
pay it and that's the the lower class or
the middle class income earners
when you start to think about how this
affects uh what people are paid we have
10.5 million open rules in america
highest that there's ever been uh
unemployment still hovering around five
percent or so how do you think about
wages uh the hourly rate minimum wage
you know some of the data that we
recently looked at was 80 of american
workers now make over 15 an hour amazon
just committed to hiring tens of
thousands of new workers some of them
they're going to pay 18 an hour like how
do you just view the wages and the
movement that we've seen in the last 18
months and where we're going on that
front yeah well wages are going up for a
number of reasons in addition to
inflation wages are going up because the
government is incentivizing people not
to work
and so therefore you have to pay them
even more money to encourage them to
give up those incentives because all
else being equal people prefer leisure
to work so if the government makes you a
good deal not to work the employers have
to make you an even better deal to work
and then of course you have things like
the minimum wage law and occupational
licensing and other things workman's
comp social security other
regulations that the government
implements that drive up the cost of
hiring people and therefore
you know wages are are being pushed up
um all of this ultimately has to be
borne by the consumer of the products
because whatever it costs a company to
employ the labor
all of those costs have to be made up by
the end customer in whatever good or
services they're buying and obviously
the people who are most impacted are the
elderly people who are living on fixed
incomes because they're not getting
wages their incomes are fixed and yet
their costs are going way up uh the
people who are you know getting pay
increases
uh have a little bit of a cushion
although again my my thinking is all
these people who are taking these 15 an
hour jobs with these 18 hour jobs
those increases are not even going to be
enough to cover what they're about to
experience
as far as their cost of living so they
would have been better off if they were
still earning less money and their cost
of living hadn't gone up as much because
they're going to be behind the the curve
and also what's going to happen is a lot
of these jobs because of how much more
expensive they are they're going to end
up getting eliminated so a lot of people
will be priced out of the market
businesses will automate they'll they'll
off you know they'll outsource or some
companies will just go out of business
entirely that their customers will not
be able to afford their services
if they have to pay those rates and so
they end up you know closing up shop and
now now they don't need to hire anybody
because they don't have a business
anymore hey guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofi
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help